[Music]
earlier today i was at my one of my
favorite sandwich places um
unfortunately it's not a little mom and
pop uh it was a chain my favorite chain
i should say jersey mike's not an ad
don't be ashamed though because they're
a very good company they do a lot of
charitable things oh yeah i've heard
that and also the boss does this really
fun thing where every year he has a
convention and apparently he does the
thing where he like picks a person who
has the most pride in the company and he
like gives them their own store that's
right i was there and i was um ordering
my favorite i was ordering sandwich for
you and the lady
was about to slather on some mayo on
mine i said oh no no sorry um uh not
that one and i was sort of instructing
her that i didn't want it mike's way she
was about to add something else i didn't
want so i said oh no i'm sorry very
polite i was very polite i kind of
pointed over the counter a little bit
and she
she goes
keep your hands away
something like that like pretty uh
did you point how many inches away from
her face no i was so far away i was
right it was hovering above the counter
and they're like little package things
on the couch i wasn't anywhere near the
food but it was a weird little i think
maybe power move anyway how did you
rectify the situation i just laid on the
kindness i was just i was even nicer uh
and she i pointed me in the direction of
the bathroom and i thanked her and i
called her ma'am that's happy ending
yeah okay and here's a happy beginning
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your uh recently completed a happy
ending
host justin long
[Music]
with me as always is
my um my co-pilot my uh partner in crime
my you also like a happy ending
christian who doesn't like a happy
ending i know i think unfortunately the
term happy ending has been corrupted
by uh
well uh oh
it's a term i mean when we were kids
it's like you know fairy tales or that's
that's what that was the crazy thing
about empire strikes back i remember
watching that movie and it was the first
movie i saw that didn't have a happy
ending i mean it was like kind of a
it was a middle it was a hap it wasn't
even a happy middle it was like a empire
strikes back yeah spoiler alert oh right
that's true nicole buyer's gonna
watch that she's gonna have spoiled for
her um i guess people have had a long
time to see that movie yeah what's the
time limit on a spoiler alert ten years
10. i don't know i just made that at all
um well anyway yeah that i remember
thinking like wait what that's that's it
i don't think there is a tie sorry i
don't think there is a time limit
because even a movie like casablanca you
still shouldn't
spoil that movie because i know but like
you give people a chance to see it at
any point in their lives i should always
say just to be safe spoiler alert you
can't say spoiler alert and then say the
spoil
and and expect that it's going to
rectify having just ruined something i
know well that's i've noticed that
people do that they say they spoiler
alert they go right into
this sport spoiler alert casablanca also
doesn't have a happy ending really i
mean spoiler alert who's the kind i'm
forgetting is it catherine hepburn she
leaves no it's not catholic maybe not
today maybe not tomorrow but someday
you're gonna regret it if you stay here
wait it's not gonna be not today maybe
not um who is that champagne for the
rest of your life well i guess if you
guys haven't seen casablanca yet now you
don't have to well yeah i was
i'm pretty bogart
i'm from ingrid bergman ingrid bergman
yeah god man we are pathetic brothers
such a dumb boomer i know
not even good bro maybe we should rename
the show from life is short to dumb
it's kind of a funny name for a podcast
it's a funny name anyway um that was
that was not really a happy ending why
are we talking about happy endings well
i'll tell you because at the beginning
because our guest today
uh was the star of the huge tv hit happy
endings our guest is a very funny a very
nice man he's one of my i i've always
liked him um and i'm so glad we got to
have him on the show our guest is adam
pally
he is um he's a pal he he's an
acquaintance but um he's he i would like
him to be a pal i would say it's more
than an acquaintance yeah at this point
for sure he was like at this point i'm
saying even before the interview we ran
into him at the knicks game yeah two
years ago yeah and he's fun too you talk
to him a lot yeah more than more than a
that was not an acquaintance oh really i
don't think so he doesn't have
acquaintance energy no but i think i've
only seen him enough to qualify as an
acquaintance do you know what i mean
yeah i know you mean um yeah you haven't
logged enough hours with him exactly
like his buddy ben schwartz yes like one
of his closest friends well ben friend
of the show benjamin yes friend of the
show i feel similarly about ben where
like i haven't spent that much time with
him but i fee we have a more pally
energy mm-hmm about not adam palley but
appalling i know what you mean um anyway
adam is um just so funny so quick he's
one of the original
uh improv guys ucb guys um not one of
the original ones he's not 80. but um
he's uh
he would i'll tell you this he'd have a
really funny quip about how i'm totally
massacring this introduction
what would he say oh that's
that's great thanks a lot do you mind if
i just
come on the show now that's good yeah
he's got the chicago yeah he's kind of
um very dry
and uh he's quick he's quick and dry
he's somebody i've seen on stage and
he's so i mean like ben a great
combination quick and dry yes yeah quick
and dry oof it's lethal i know it's hard
to beat that vince vaughn jake johnson
those guys are quick and dry yeah um and
uh it's always so fun to talk to him i'm
really happy to catch you happy it was a
happy beginning middle and then
full circle so we talk about that show
we talk about um his new movie he's in
sonic the hedgehog 2 with ben schwartz
the aforementioned you know the hedgehog
2 starting to interrupt
got did so well at the box office the
opening weekend it like shattered
records and right away they announced on
a hedgehog 3. are you serious oh it made
like
it was jim carrey's biggest opening ever
you're kidding jim carrey holy [ __ ] yeah
i made like 75 million dollars opening
weekend
is that wild domestically oh good for
that well now i remember um not to make
it about me
when alvin and the chipmunks had done
really well the second one
similarly like that this the squeak of
all movies did like crazy and i mean not
it's not like the hedgehog numbers no i
have animation jealousy
um but i thought jim carrey was gonna i
thought he was retiring didn't he
announce that he was retiring from
acting yes now he's back in wow he's got
to do part three wow good for him i'm
i'm glad i root for jim carrey i really
like him me too i think he's and ben and
hopefully future friend of the show jim
carrey that'd be great man he is just
he's a sage he's what a legend uh you
know who else is really talented and
funny who adam pelly let's hear from him
let's do it okay here he is the very as
i said the very quick and dry
adam pally
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
here we are with adam he's a little late
but um
thank you so much thank you so much for
watching sorry
that was adam uh i knocked over your
phone
um oh my god where you're in a hotel
room
adam's drinking pellegrino fancy what
city are you in i'm in atlanta
of course it's a weird gig to be in
atlanta i'm doing a um a travel show i'm
doing a version of the trip like an
american trip oh man that's great yeah
it's so fun with who adam with my uh
buddy who i actually um
have been improvising doing comedy with
for 20 years gail gabris oh gabries yeah
i'd love to do it with gil but gill is
glock kosher but what does that mean it
means you're like strict oh wow i didn't
know it makes like trying beef and
cheese empanadas and puerto rico
challenging gil is my most like talmudic
friend where like if there's a
philosophy question on life like how do
you feel about something or is this
jewish or not like i go to gil and be
like you know what's how should i feel
about israel you know yeah yeah and yeah
he is always very clear-headed and on
this subject we disagree
and i think that he has the most logical
standpoint of why to keep kosher that
i've ever heard to connect with
like he's like i get the logic is off
but it makes me feel
like i'm unique and a jewish person if i
just don't eat those things i don't know
if this is the proper analogy but it's
like when i've dated i dated a vegan
woman once and like i became a vegan
temporarily not so much
i had always aspired to do that for
health and like ethical reasons but like
that's not what
eventually compelled me to do it was
just to kind of like connect with her
you're on the same team yeah it's like
those relationships is i always wonder
if it would be hard to be like an addict
with someone who's not
recovered or does drink it's like that
would be very challenging because you're
not on the same team totally and that's
a basic that's like a pillar of who they
are
either someone who can't drink or it's
someone who is jewish or it's someone
who doesn't eat meat that seems to be
like a pretty like it's not like
somebody who just like um
like likes basketball or something i
think that's it's not as superficial as
that like yeah no but it's it's true
it's like i think and especially in a
marriage like you're in a relationship
you're always looking for things to keep
you on the same team
right
being in a healthy relationship is
something that i've always
aspired to and it's always eluded me and
i know you you have three kids and
you've been together for a long time i
have three children now yeah we've been
together forever and
we're in hollywood you know so it's like
well now we're in new york now we're in
harlem but when i get back please come
up i mean i would love that adam i
remember seeing you at the knicks we
were at that knicks game i don't
remember what a couple years ago
my brother was like that's a guy you
could be friends with you know like i i
so rarely meet people where i'm like oh
i could be friend especially the older i
get them it's so rare to imagine but i
um i remember thinking i consider you my
og in a lot of ways because you know
i've been kicking around
a beat
yeah yeah i feel like i met you really
young early on and you were super super
welcoming and nice to me
and i don't even know if you remember it
but you were so sweet and nice to me and
it was like i i remember thinking like
that's how you do it like i was brought
to your house by liz kakowski to swim
was i there
you were in the beginning and then you
showed up yeah i was on an improv team
when i was like 22 with liz and she had
just gotten on snl because and had just
met uh akiva and i guess the boys were
staying at your house this has happened
so many times where because yeah so but
akiva had been renting so akiva from
people listening lonely island uh ikevi
yorman and yorman to come and andy was
saying there too because that's how
maybe
that's how i ended up there was like no
i was like and then i was like wow i
remember being like and justin's cool
with me being here
like
he's like i don't know i was like what
do you mean you don't know like well i i
like didn't know i keep it that well but
i i always liked those guys so much and
obviously thought they were so funny and
um i don't know how it happened but like
i think i just volunteered my he was
like oh i'm looking for a place to stay
like i think he was in between houses i
think he had just gotten married or
something was gone and
i was just like we'll stay at my place
and
i i don't and and he and i was gonna be
gone i was working somewhere and um
i don't i don't remember my memory so
bad i don't know if you volunteered to
pay me and i turned it down or i
accepted i was like i mean i get i
remember thinking like i feel weird
taking money from akiva
like ed sheeran sleeps on your couch you
know what i mean i've often been
compared to yeah i think of you as a
jamie foxx but anyway no you were just
like so nice to like [ __ ] with one x
yeah yeah yeah oh jamie fox like cause
he's from yeah
[Laughter]
but but also over the years i've like
run into so many people it'll be at some
hollywood thing usually where it's like
somebody had really like some funny
person such as yourself comes up to me
and they're like stay at your house for
a couple weeks like i know you're happy
like eva must have
it seems like he's a conduit to like
every funny person in hollywood because
i i meet them
yeah i mean the loneliness first of all
the three of them are
how did you know them
through liz and also like just from andy
was on snl with in the years that i was
like in new york
working a lot as a comedian but not yet
broke really you know like so is it most
it was at ucb was it ucb mostly but
around it was like pianos and stuff and
like you know oh yeah i was kind of like
at that point where i could have gone to
l.a but i stayed a little bit longer
because i was like big fish in it and
like you know feeling good and but not
yet like nothing had clicked i i had
done a move i had done a movie with
angley that i kind of got cut out of
and it's such a funny name to like kind
of mention just like casually and like a
disparaging like yeah [ __ ] angly put
me in a movie yeah i was supposed to be
like you know everyone has those though
like it's like adrian yeah the thin red
line you know like yes
yeah totally i remember that everyone
has a moment where you get a part and
you're like this is it like angley cast
me out of a [ __ ] commercial a meal
hersh and we have schreiber it's like
[ __ ] you get there and you're like
watching it not
work out and then you
they you get that call it's like
any wants you to know that you were
great but
the movie went a different direction
you're like oh okay
you got entirely cut out
pretty much
whoa yeah that's rough six yeah i was
like i have a couple lines but it's like
i went my parents were like must be hard
to make a movie huh cause you were there
a long time oh and i was like trying to
yeah
oh parents parental sympathy is tough
tough trying to mask but but like
masking it was like
it's you know
this is a life lesson that's like it's
tough to make a movie it's a funny way
to go oh yeah because it's like i get
what you're saying like he it was a huge
deal like i missed the vacation they
were telling everybody oh adam is
shooting with angley i was like 23. it
was the movie after brokeback mountain
so it was like man yes yes it's like
yeah adam's becoming's new muse yeah
that's what i told him
i was like six on the call sheet because
it was like wow like there a lot that
you know yeah wow playing a real guy i
like went and met him [ __ ] wow he was
like really socked yeah
yeah who was the guy did the guy
in his was
schwartz i believe and he was um
one of the guys that that ended up being
credited with starting woodstock but he
was
truly
he walked into it by being like high all
the time and ended up like hanging out
and they liked his vibe
there was a lot to do but he was like
always there i had i would have like
these comedic lines and then like
i'd improvise also on set and like yeah
well i'm sure that's what he wanted you
i'm sure he cast you in part because you
could do that yeah but then it was like
i realized like i saw it like not like
going i saw it like going away you know
like yeah oh really was it was it eggs
was it his energy was would he laugh
what because he's a very yeah
no no he would not laugh at me
in fact eugene levy
easy levy
um said to me on one of the days he said
um because i i'm sure he was going
through a similar thing yeah yeah i bet
he said to me he cleaned it and he said
you know that's the biggest non-laugh
i've ever seen someone get
that's
that's funny
because i took like a huge swing i like
try
it took a huge swing in my close-up you
know
[ __ ] dead dead dead like
just drinking
crickets and you and i know you know i'm
looking for like yeah someone to give me
something look over eugene like a sad
the sound guy to be like
yeah yes
again
all these big names skyler asked him
this guy's like just just on like spring
awakening is looking away from me
it's like watching somebody take a [ __ ]
it's like that way you know and it's
like it wasn't in the script but i
decided to do something
yeah
you know like [ __ ] ended up drinking
nine chocolate milks and like close up
eugene is just like you [ __ ] idiot
there's like icons judging you
everywhere that's yeah everywhere and
like the fact that i i think that also
is a testament to just like you really
do have to be like dumb not dumb but
like your ego has to be so strong but
mine is not strong mine is like
ryan is like delusional in a way it's
like i know it's like hey so it's almost
like what's it called like a uh like a
security
you know defense so you fight back by
being like well i can do anything but
it's shocking that i did not quit i i
was thinking that when i was watching
the kanye yay i always thought it was yi
really but it's yeah i did i like his
new
nickname which is jesus it's not is it
yeah
is it really yeah how do you know this
how do we learn this i've been obsessed
with kanye i mean he's from chicago we
like having all their stuff
lost his mom like i've been obsessed
with kanye since i was a kid
so like i i've seen everything i follow
everything i don't necessarily like it
but yes
what i mean
i hate to talk about it like i see i
don't i mean i'm like i'm just kind of
discovering him and and i'm fascinated
by him after watching this documentary
but i and and now i'm like listening to
graduates and i'm like getting into it
um oh gradually i mean his music changed
like
i think it's just like the the
the blueprint even and going back even
further like
that's when i became like in love with
hip-hop and i i just like remember him
specifically having some sort of like
male energy that i attached to where i
was like i
get it i get him i get his style i like
everything he's doing it's not flashy
but it is flashy it's like but he also
expresses insecurities he expresses like
yes he's so funny and he's so funny he's
funny yeah he's just like he's the
funniest you can't there's no other
rapper that has his sense of humor
that's true maybe that's what it is that
that i'm like i mean that's what i love
about i mean to have a single like one
of his best singles has the chorus since
oj wore isa toners
so that yeah i that i should have had i
mean i remember
the zack alfinakis video that i just
just the fact that he gave zach
galifianakis who at the time i remember
i knew zach practice he no people didn't
know who he was no he maybe had that
that that comedy central special with
the great ending where he's like uh
dancing in the dress you ever see that
no the purple not the purple well before
it was pretty before
oh no
central was giving out like half hours
to people you know and his half hour was
amazing oh [ __ ] i gotta see that uh i
think it's called like what was it
called like real i think it had like a
ham pun
i like that
i've got a google ham pun
gal connect um and that's someone who
also like really appreciates comedy
somebody who values it he did a uh
here's a here's a unknown
kanye west fact he did a
curb your enthusiasm style pilot for hbo
that larry charles directed where
matt walsh and
ian roberts coached him in improv
and it it didn't make it to series larry
charles directed it holy [ __ ] there's
footage of it the tape exists i've never
seen it but he did it after curb like
remember curb was like the biggest thing
for a little bit yeah everywhere you
know sure yeah it inspired him to do a
kanye west there's a kanye west no
kidding no oh how badly you haven't seen
it i don't think you capture it's like
oh wow i've only heard like crazy
stories and stuff and
i just haven't got
killed to see that footage watching this
documentary and hearing these stories in
the context of like now i'm so
fascinated by what this display is you
know the current like him going after
pete and like all this stuff it's like
oh well
i've i have theories on it and i yeah
i don't feel as though it's not i i
think he has he's got a lot of stuff
mentally
that is like
very similar to trump in a way that's
like the pete stuff didn't matter it's
not pee pee doesn't give a [ __ ] about
pee pee could be anybody
it's it's that on the day of the super
bowl he was trending it's like a
it's like a megalomaniac
maniacal need
to have a tension on you at all times
well you can see the seeds of it in the
document like the scene
like and like unchecked like where that
might go if his mind that's why his
mother seemed to be such a like our
mother is such
my mom died at the same age that his did
and so like i remember
just like i get it i get it i i get
going off the handle you know like i
obviously you know i i can't imagine
that's the part that was the part where
and seeing what a like lovely
i mean talking about supportive and like
what a woman what a smart she
was she knew that she needed to take
care of him she knew he had stuff like
he exhibited mental problems from from
the moment you see him you meet him
you're like he's spectrum
not to be like not to be like uh uh
blase about it no it's very clear you're
like something's up there he's not his
eye contact is flawed he's many geniuses
are i think he's a i think genius i
think i think i suffer from it i i know
it i think geniusness
do you say geniusness yeah yeah no i
don't suffer from that yeah no no no i
suffered from like um i don't know i
don't want to say
spectrum related
mental
anything like that but i don't i think i
am similar to a lot of comedians like
my social cues tend to value
humor
or or puts humor in a way to cope as
instead of the proper emotional response
that makes
yes i've seen that in a lot of i think
that that's probably a common factor a
lot of comedians there i think so
i think so you see it when comedians get
together it's um it's just blobbing i
mean it's that's why we like each other
right because we have like
you know like we get on because we're
like oh there's a certain sociopathic
nature that i can say anything to you
but yes i love you yes and that's how i
express my affection right it's through
those things i think real people
i think that that sometimes when you go
out in the real i know when you go into
the real world
it doesn't work like that you know you
have to be genuine yeah so has that been
where are you now in that journey i mean
have you are there things that have
helped you cope with that are there
because i i've tried kalonicken ones i
and meditation's really helped me but i
i have a i'm similarly wired i think and
i've reverted to well like obviously
there are things that like i think a lot
of people
you know therapy medication
you know
all that stuff is
essential you know to find the right mix
of like i've been on antidepressants
since i was like
22
you know because they suffer from
depression you know uh
and so you find the right mix that lets
you go on daily and sometimes that can
take two years and sometimes that can
take five years and sometimes that
should take 10 years but if you do the
medication
in
congress with
with therapy whether it's once a week or
twice a week or once a month as long as
you have someone that you
check in with and talk to
i think that that has helped me a lot
like normalize the way i feel make it
feel kind of like oh well that's just my
out this is my alchemy you know
so you become more comfortable
in how you react which is really all we
want you don't resist it in that way yes
exactly like yeah what we want is like
less less just yes right totally so then
and then i feel like i rely a lot on
um
my
own like i
i know that i'm a warm person
and so sometimes i put up a
a comedic like
kind of like
edge because i think i can like outwit
it in a way yeah yeah that's interesting
is it
like a sardonic uh how would you
how about on a distance
is something which i think you know can
hurt relationships and all that stuff
but i think as i've grown older and i've
learned how to like harness stuff i feel
like i'm i'm way more able to like just
be who i want to who i want to put out
who i want to be you know a lot more
it's like you're getting out of your own
way it's like you're allowing yourself
permission to be to feel uncomfortable
just to feel things that aren't to to
sit in the feelings send that
text to the you know someone you
think is cool and they don't text back
and you're like [ __ ] that who cares like
you know you just like free yourself for
that stuff and then you let people say
whatever they want about you you know
and you're like all right
i know it's uh that's i know that's
something that i can't wait to really
master that you know i i don't know who
the ultimate who the goal is somebody
like clint eastwood even though i'm sure
clint eastwood has who knows what he is
i mean
he was pretty i mean stoic for sure
stoic i think that if you can yeah i
think that it takes a lot to feel that
confident you know yeah
and well well look at kanye he's not
he's clearly struggling with
insecurities and like he i mean he's
waging this public think this cri it's
like feels like a cry for help and
god
is a cry for help and really
i think that that is we do that a lot
with people like that we emp we we
empathize foreign
he doesn't feel that i think i i i think
you have to look at him like the way you
look at trump trump yeah huh that's
interesting this is like and i you know
i [ __ ] hate trump i mean i created
the president show you know like yeah
yes that's right you know like was
almost [ __ ] like fbi material but i
like i think that that when you think of
both of them does trump really
think that any of those things
does he really believe in any no he's
only thinking about trump and how to
like push trump forward that's what
connie is doing and the bummer is that
to me when he was more confident
probably because mother was there and he
wasn't scared about what death means and
stuff like when he was more confident
his music was better
and he was able to like live
there's something more honest about it
yeah i was more honest because like i
read a review about his last album
and it was like kanye's new album is
always just kanye so the music now
is like a way to get people to click or
talk about him it's the same way that he
does a photo shoot with julia fox or
like whatever it's all just
worked off for kanye and like
i think part of that's true
[Music]
feeling the effects of sleepless nights
well not lately no i haven't been either
i was asking i guess the uh the
listening public oh i'm sorry i was
asking you i know you haven't been
because you've been using plus cbd sleep
gummies that's right to get the rest
that you need to wake up feeling focused
and refreshed and ready for a day o
podcast these tasty raspberry gummies
are made with award-winning cbd along
with melatonin magnolia bark and lemon
balm for powerful sleep support they won
awards for their cbd that's an award
show i would like to go to and the plus
cbd sleep gummies are safe to use every
night for better rest and uh
i'm glad that's true because i have been
using them every night did you just
realize they were safe yeah
it's a relief to read that all plus cbd
products are third party tested and
fully traceable from seed to shelf so
you can be assured you're getting the
highest quality hemp cbd on those days
you just need a little positive push
plus cbd is the perfect go-to product
the pure ingredients can help reduce
stress alleviate soreness and improve
your overall sleep and plus cbd is san
diego's trusted cbd brand and the number
one selling natural hemp extract in the
u.s so shop now at plus cbd
pluscbdoil.com enter promo code long
l-o-n-g
for 40 off your order
did you know that in the last year rates
of anxiety and depression have doubled
in the us doubled these days it can take
weeks to get a traditional therapy
appointment but now you don't have to
wait with cerebral cerebral is an online
mental health service that offers
prescription medication counseling and
therapy for anxiety depression adhd
insomnia and more it's one of the few
services that provides prescription
medication online through a licensed
provider and ships medication straight
to your door so you can skip the
pharmacy lines and now with the app the
cerebral mobile app it's like having
your personal care team wherever you are
you can message your care team and
access self-care resources from wherever
whenever
however not however you have to use the
app you can connect with a counselor and
a therapist on your own schedule through
your laptop or cerebro mobile app you
can schedule sessions based on what's
most convenient for you so you have to
wait weeks to be seen
eighty percent of our members see a
provider within five days and treatment
options are available with or without
insurance and for listeners of this
program you can receive 65 percent off
your first month of medication
management and care counseling at
cerebral.com
long just go to cerebral dot com slash
long for 65 percent off your first month
that's just a total of thirty dollars to
get started join cerebral today on their
mission to make quality mental health
care accessible and affordable for all
hello hello
[Music]
it's interesting i was just watching the
seinfeld where um not that there's
anything wrong with that episode and
it's a masterpiece but you watch it now
through the lens of like a more tolerant
diverse time and it is it's like so what
i know and when they say now that
there's anything wrong with that it
comes off as hollow because the whole
joke is
there is a little something
wrong with that to them to them yeah the
joke is like
you guys are something wrong with it but
like makes you it's a lot seinfeld is
another one i think it has way more
virtues than than not but it's another
one where it pulls out and you go like
they're not just horrible people
they're like racist and and homophobic
yeah you know it's not just like the end
is like they go to jail but the the
ending is really tough too like i don't
know if you've watched the last one i
haven't in a while i know they
incorporate everything was that the one
that
they end up yeah they end up in jail but
they incorporate everybody but it does
have the vibe of four white people being
sued by
every minority in the city
i never seen it
i'm just imagining that now it does i
mean it's like it's not that they're not
doing that and they're my idols like
blindfolds i love them they're larry
they're my favorites i hope that they
would not take offense this by being
like you gotta look back at the work you
know at someone especially like unhappy
endings i've been i've gotten oh really
i would
yes like problematic stuff that where
you're like
yeah it's problematic if it was to
reboot would i do it i wouldn't would
you
i don't know would you well i always
often wonder that about stuff not that
far removed i was talking to the new
girl guys on their on their podcast
about some one episode in particular
where the schmidt character
tries to ingratiate himself with with
winston who is the black character and
not to reduce him to that for the
purposes of this i
it's it's important lamorne played that
part and um
schmidt was trying to
he affected a different vernacular he
spoke in what he thought was more like a
black dialect you know i mean he it was
offense offensive
and there and they were arguing that
that should be can't i don't know what
what the solution is but but that it was
problematic and i don't know it's
obvious it's really hard to talk about
this stuff but i i i just talked to the
z-way about it on her show so that was
great
it's like i think i would want to do it
because it's a question i feel like a
lot of actors are afraid to ask
themselves in a lot of ways and i'm and
i'm kind of like in a lot of times that
i deal with if there are fans or like or
whatever people that watch the show
there is that question quite a bit and
so yeah i feel like it's like you know i
don't know it's something that i would
have to think about and have to like get
i have people discussed how it's
problematic i haven't seen it in a while
i think it's disgusting it's problematic
i mean the thing about the the character
that was good was like the whole thing
about it was that there was no
affectation
there were story lines about it but it
wasn't about
that it was like just regular casual
dating stories and stuff yeah yeah
treated as if there was nothing it was
just he was a gay character in fact he
was the biggest stoner slob evil which
breaks which kind of breaks this gay
stereotype at the time in one of kevin's
movies i played a gay character and
as as much as i loved that character and
loved the experience i um
kevin asked me to do that character
again he was a gay porn star and it
didn't really work because
it felt different to do
what's the joke right right that he
wants to [ __ ] a guy that he wants to
[ __ ] a guy you know it's like okay see
i still think the character and he cut
all this out so you would but i there
was a joe mangianello was in the scene
and i i played it that i was so
horny for joe like i was doing
everything i could to get near him you
could argue
that it's it's funny to be that
aggressively sexual but it's kind of
that's hard to get away with and it's
hard to
make that funny now now after like
the litany of people who have like been
exposed for for being sexually
aggressive and like it's just hard to
laugh at that now it's like that's that
i that i think feels like too soon it is
and i think that that is something that
like i'm always now people are like has
comedy changed or like how do you feel
about caring culture different i'm
always like i don't know i like i
tend to censor myself more in a good way
yeah yeah yeah
i know that we were taking pictures for
sonic the hedgehog too
and because my character is like kind of
chubby in the movie they handed me a
bagel
and
they were taking these stills with the
bagel like for the posters
and i was like i'm sorry i don't feel
like super comfortable standing here
with a bagel yeah and they're like what
are they funny you're like they're like
oh you think we're making fun of
your jewishness yeah they were like why
because you're a jew i was like
yeah you just said it you knew it and i
was like the whole stereotype of cops is
a donut
why do i have right
right
they're like you're right you're right
hold this menorah instead yeah they were
like uh and then it was like a huge
[ __ ] likes like the ad agency's
talking with this they bring the
director
over no kidding yeah i was just like
because that's what was written it was
like well yep yeah
adam's character holds a bagel but the
fact that someone wrote that is like i
know so i was like i'd rather not hold a
bagel if you want to do a funny thing
with a cop i'll be like cleaning out my
gun like look at another thing they're
like yeah do that
right i censored that yep yeah i just
what do you what do you do with
but what about i was watching that but
you got to see that you may have seen it
the don rickles documentary yes but what
do you do with that i was watching some
of this stuff and like
i don't i mean it's it's it's wild
i met don before he died
he he made a joke about jews it was at
this like comedy award show and he and i
had presented and he saw it and then
someone's like don wants to meet you and
i was like yeah you know came over and
he's like another jew in hollywood and
it was like [ __ ]
let's go dude like you're like pulling
at low hanging fruit and then i've heard
like real like stories like i had a
friend who was like overweight who in
the 90s went to see don rickles in vegas
and they came up to him and they were
like would you like to sit in the front
row like while he was waiting to go in
and he was like yeah sure and he went up
in the front row and then like don comes
out and immediately starts going at him
like that guy in the
and then he audience
looks down
in the audience and he sees like
every
different kind of ethnicity and minority
wow that's like talk about kaiser jose
moment that's
yeah i and then you hear like the kevin
hart story
with don rickles and it's like he's sold
on harrison is tough all right
yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah
god i've seen some of those like him on
on some of those old carson franco's
carson appearances even him on letterman
like later the one with denzel you could
tell how much denzel loves him and like
the way he's so like cheeky and seems
like so there's such affection that he
has for people i there's something so
lovable about him well like look like
everyone likes to get their balls busted
yeah yeah yeah especially in hollywood
because it makes you totally that's why
people laugh but they're you're right
because it makes you look like you can
take it is it going after people that
are somewhat deserve is there some what
is the what is the equation like what's
the formula if you could reduce it to an
equation i feel like it's common sense
as dumb as that sounds it's like very
easy and clear to see like who's a
decent person and not you're gonna make
fun of something and it is through the
lens of like gay panic or racism or
whatever it's pretty easy to see you're
like it's not funny anymore what were
your like movies growing up what were
the ones that like
made you fall in love with comedy who
who are your guys don't throw mama from
the train
billy crystal in that movie is at the
top of his like game just playing i
don't know that movie that well i gotta
i gotta watch that movie
gene wilder a lot of like
yeah you know stir crazy um
oh yeah
you know evil you know you know young
frankenstein i love i and then like late
steve martin before before cheaper by
the dozens you weren't like father like
roxanne yeah roxanne father of the bride
that's all the same era to me that's
kind of what i
what i what i saw as a child was like
that's what i can do i can do that i can
make people feel that today ah that's
interesting i i that just came up the
other day somebody was talking about uh
that that moment in l.a story i think
that a lot when
when somebody when he's talking to that
woman at a dinner party and she's like
being very unresponsive and he and he
said oh and when he's trying to make
conversation with her and she and he's
like
and what do you do she's like i'm a
student oh where ucla what are you
majoring in conversation oh do you do
you enjoy that yes
yeah that's his most like ellie's story
is him as most woody allen
yeah it's like you can tell steve martin
was thinking of himself as like he's
like you know what i'm gonna write and
direct these things now
yeah i think where he hid his best is
bowfinger
oh my god yes adam i just rewatched that
i showed you you know isn't it great to
show people you i just showed my
girlfriend that she hadn't seen it to
people whose sense of humor you really
appreciate yeah
mind blown mind blown she was like where
is this been and i love
like it's like watching it for the first
time and eddie murphy yes eddie murphy
oh [ __ ] is he both of them that's and
the direction thank god that the like
i mean
now what about
what about bob a joe versus volcano he's
a sleeper i mean yes i gotta re-watch
that
uh tom hanks his early work to me is
very like you know sleepless in seattle
my brother was important to me and then
i think i got like when i hit
professional age when i was like oh i'm
gonna start doing this
it was post tarantino
and it was like soderbergh that i was
like that's what i was watching and like
like out of sight like out of sight the
limey
this dude's [ __ ] doing it and and
that's kind of that that was like my
that that's what i wanted to do was like
heist movies and romantic comedies
huh yeah no kidding have you gotten to
do a heist movie no not yet i i've been
like developed i keep like developing
one and i want to do it i had one that
we should do i can't get the idea right
but it's my grandfather told me a story
that he believed that there was gold in
the holland tunnel huh because he
believed that when the jews came over
they wouldn't just leave the gold he's
like that is [ __ ] whoever told you
that the jews left their money and their
paintings and all that [ __ ] in austria
and ran from the germans he's like i'm
here to tell you my father did not do
that you know and i was just a hunch it
was like he wouldn't have done that yeah
he's like yeah he's like he wouldn't
have done that
and he was like there is gold and the
only way you could get at the time
ellis island was to go to jersey
and the holland tunnel was being built
at that time and so he's like i'm
convinced that like five jews came over
hid gold there and so i was like that's
great i should get five jews to dig it
up now
yes
but i didn't know when he was shovels
yeah but we don't do manual labor we
don't do that yeah i have an italian
cousin who has a truck
he used it to bury jimmy hoffa um
you know what would be like the sappy
sentimental ending of that is like
we go looking for the gold the riches
and like we dig it up and it's like just
like
personal valuables from these families
you know like letters and journals
diaries and yeah yeah and all and you
read them and it's like
the streets are paved with gold in the
united states yes yes yes this is our
dream this is our yes yes you defined
for your generations for generations of
yours to grow and be free and find these
yeah and to hold on to what's important
i think we just wrote it i think we did
and then my character is like so there's
no [ __ ] money
yeah that would be tough because we need
one of the jewish characters to not care
about money so i'm not sure how we get
around that yeah
from australia yeah australia honestly
the australian jews have an added layer
of survival it's like we survived that
and then we got survived all the way
again over here so we're yolks yeah on a
pinot colony yeah
criminals
how did you meet bench towards ben a
friend of the show bounce once
i and did you was it was it one of those
things where it's like my brother and i
were just talking about this like you
know you click right away it's like love
it's like it's like it's i'm not
thinking about steve martin movies it's
live right yeah it was true love we met
i know that date we met speaking of so
ben and i were coming up at the ucb like
kind of different
fashion like
we knew each other knew of each other
for sure but we were not friendly you
know and then
word got around that tina was gonna do a
special showcase for
these two comedians from la who they
were really considering andy sandberg
and bill hader and so the entire upright
citizens brigade everyone that had taken
a class everyone and this is early early
on so it's like not that big a theater
showed up to be like who the [ __ ] is
getting a showcase
so everyone shows up and i'm in a seat
next to my buddy and i say hey i'm going
to go get a beer save the seat so he
says and i come back
and ben schwartz is sitting in my feet
uh-huh
and i was like dude i said save the seat
he's like i did i told him you're
getting a beer but he said so what sat
down
and i was like excuse me and he goes
dude i'm sorry i just like i'm the
bartender and the show's about to start
i need a place to sit can you like stand
behind me right here and i was like what
and then the show started all the lights
came down and i was behind him the whole
time
i bet seethings
yeah yeah i'm gonna kick this lanky
[ __ ] i'ma break this fucker's nose
uh-huh and the lights came up and we and
they were amazing obviously and we were
both like and
and we both made a joke about like well
i guess we're not getting on saturday
alive
what did they do do you remember what
they did what hater yes hater did
uh the italian
oh oh he's interview the interview guy
he did veni yes it all that was like the
center of it but then man
al pacino and the place
just fell down like the ceiling fell
down i've never seen anything like that
you know what i mean like
so freaking good yeah and and ben and i
were both like we saw like and andy was
just like he's doing stand-up but his
stand-up was so he looked like a muppet
you know it was like
neither of us
yeah
yeah we just started like bitterly
joking and
we were like well let's start doing
stuff and then for like but how did you
get past your like resentment that he
had [ __ ] sat in your seat that's
amazing to me because i thought he was
funny oh yeah isn't that amazing wow
yeah it'd be funny and like i didn't
want to fight with a guy i wanted to be
friends with a funny guy right right did
you ever address that were you ever like
i can't believe you're the nerve you're
talking about
oh
how does she respond how would he right
past it he's like no i didn't happen
like that like all right okay well you
stole my seat
it's really funny he had a different he
had a different comedy partner too at
the time
that i think his name was nick gibbons
gibbons and schwartz and so he was
already like famous in the theater
people like knew huh
wow you know so so this is what like
2004
earlier earlier yeah
yeah wow okay yeah cause maybe even two
yeah yeah yeah really really early and
then we started hanging out and we
clicked so hard for real it was like
finding like best friend at 20. you know
we were 20 and
he was writing for letterman we're not
really writing for them they're like
writing jokes and sending them in he's
the hardest working
comedian i've ever met you know i'm from
stuyvesant town he's from the bronx
we're both jews who like can't pass but
love basketball and right love
basketball and rap and like yeah and and
then the thing we bonded on was we were
we were frustrated with how slow comedy
was at the time in new york like people
were very into it was like
yeah it was like post comedy he was like
we're going to sit down we're going to
do a scene
and we're just going to like find the
reality of the scene before anyone like
makes a joke or anything and ben and i
are like [ __ ] that we're going to do
five scenes in
a minute and all of them will be funny
and you'll know exactly what they are we
just do it with three words or whatever
and that becomes kind of our signature
with gil when gil came
is another jew who can't pass from long
island and there really weren't that
many jews at the theater yeah wow
truly there were not that many
and we were like we want to be the
fastest
three medians
at the ucb and then we were like we
won't be the fastest three comedians
like ever
well it's it's like the robin williams
school of just like rifling ahead and
[ __ ] like throwing everything out and
keeping
the ball in the air with three people
feels um like such a feat i i had never
seen anything like that before oh yeah
it's really fun it's such a shame we
don't get to do it and ben ben is still
improvising and that's the other thing i
love about i mean i love so much about
that but like
he's still improvising and uh
and that's that's really cool i i don't
i haven't been on stage in like four
years oh really oh for real even before
the pandemic then yeah i was suffering
from a little stage fright and then the
pandemic just gave me an excuse to be
like well never have to do that again
but why where did the stage come from i
wonder i don't know improv is a young
man's game you know i got kids and a
wife
house so that's
better is sick and dying yeah
when because you had mentioned your mom
what what how old were you when that
happened i was i was um
29 when my mom died she died
10 days before my son was born
oh
man
and i had just and it was the day that i
was
that happy endings got the cover of
entertainment weekly
so i was getting recognized on the
flight home oh no
to no because they called that she died
suddenly it was started
it was yeah it was just like that okay
so like i was in lax
looking at the entertainment weekly
people were like is that you
and i like dealing with like you just
everything goes away i mean
we were shooting so i went
from set
home did the
stuff and then came back and finished
the season what was it it was a heart
attack it was yeah the brain aneurysm oh
man i'm so excited
that's okay
what's the next step like what do you
how do you put the next thing on death
every day
surprised right right question existence
constantly um i was lucky i had a kid on
the way and i was like i you know i just
got married and like my life on that
level was good so i think
i wasn't alone um
but you just feel one foot and thrown in
front of the other you [ __ ] up a lot you
know i got arrested
and you just keep kind of like hoping
that tomorrow be easier
do your siblings you lean on you you i
do have two sisters
they live within two blocks of each
other in new jersey oh my god that's wow
that's great yeah and they have kids
they have kids it's it's great it's yeah
yeah and i and that was part of the
reason we moved back to new york too
because i was like i think i want to be
um involved in that more i think
probably two years after i really had
like a
tough time like i would say
i kept going for the first year in the
second year and then happy endings got
cancelled i think i lost it after that
effort a little that was just like well
now i don't have
these people
that kind of like kept me through it
they're gone and you know like that's
what happens in hollywood you make
friends you love them and they're gone
we're gonna be in touch forever we're
gonna be best friends yeah i mean
we are and like the six of us are talk
all the time but yeah you know you're
alone again and i think i lost it a
little and like i think i delved into
wanting it more in a way huh uh yeah
that that's makes sense yeah the other
way and i was like no i want to be the
biggest [ __ ] thing yeah huh on the
planet and then maybe i won't feel like
my mom's gone you know yeah what form
did that take what i mean and what was
the wake up call from that like what was
the moment where you realized you were
you were
pursuing that that path i think making
history
was a tough time
because
i i was like trying to do my own thing
and i took big chance by doing it
because i had such a good job on the
mindy project and i was like
had fit in and like i could have wrote
that out
forever you left the mini project to do
that
yeah yeah and
i did that because i was like i wanted
it all and i don't want to wait and i
don't want it to happen when it happens
i want it to happen like right now
it just didn't feel like looking back at
it now and that show was great and i had
a great time doing it and stuff i didn't
handle it well i wasn't like good at
being in charge i wasn't good at the
other stuff like press and and
i just wasn't good at it i was like were
you angry i mean was it did it come from
a place of like yeah and i was trying
too hard and i think i really wanted
again like i wanted money and fame
because i really wanted to not feel like
rotterdam yeah
yeah bad i bet because i think also one
of the big things when you lose a parent
is
you lose the
who is it for
and and even if you even if you like are
doing it for me i love doing my job but
you're like who cares if i'm on the
cover of a magazine or who cares if i
get a promotion it's like my parents
dead and my father was having a tough
time obviously there was no one to give
it to me at the time so i wanted it from
everybody
and i could feel it i could feel like my
mind kind of altering and then and it
didn't work and the show was like not
accepted
and it was a tough feeling
and it was and it was highly i remember
like that was from miller and lord right
that was like a million yeah or lord i
was like
i called him miller and lord yeah it was
it was the big one and i love you yeah
yeah yeah brilliant it just kind of like
flopped and i and
and again like i look back on it and
it's good it's not my work it's my
i was doing so much yeah yeah so much
trying hard yeah you could feel it yeah
yeah taking swings i think that's when
it changed and then i did a play
um
that kind of changed a lot for me too
right after that i moved my family to
new york i did play that's so
interesting what was the play it was
called cardinal and it was a drama about
chinese immigrant immigration
about a town dealing with bureaucracy
and stuff i played a mayor a lot of
bureaucracy dialogue
and
and the writer and we had to be word
perfect like that's what i wanted i
wanted interesting yeah yeah yeah
similarly to the other thing i was like
show me an improviser like show me one
of my contemporaries that [ __ ]
did broadway it made me feel like
maybe you can get it that way maybe
that's what you're looking for is like a
michael jordan tom brady-esque feeling
of like
[ __ ] set your goals as being like
heart [ __ ] and that'll make you feel
good the way your mom made you feel for
being funny you know
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hey parents this one's for you
wondering's kids and family podcast
little stories everywhere transports
your family to an imaginative world with
enchanting stories and exciting
adventures in each episode hosts
virginia madsen and robbie damond read
an original children's tale if you've
been looking for screen free
entertainment for your kids little
stories everywhere encourages your
little ones to use their imaginations in
one of their latest tales you'll hear
about mark the unicorn he's just like
any other unicorn except he doesn't have
a horn that makes him an easy target for
school bullies that is
until he runs into the most popular
unicorn in school sprinkles and their
unexpected adventure changes his life
forever listen to little stories
everywhere on amazon music apple
podcasts or listen early and ad free by
joining wondering plus kids in apple
podcasts or wondering plus in the
wondery app
hello hello
[Music]
i have a lightning round if you don't
mind um please but but before that i i i
have to ask you i've been so curious
about this for so long
the funny or die live stream i'm sure
you're sick of talking about this the
entourage live stream i'm not sick of
talking
well because i went back and watched i
watched the series not too long ago
which is why i mean but you know
considering what we were talking about
earlier it is crazy to watch you through
a more modern class again that is
culturally gills gill is a genius on so
many levels but that was his brainchild
yes that was guilt
that was one of the first
times i think that comedically we were
like let's look at some of these things
that have been put on television and
like see how that and how it's aged well
so just for people listening it's so
what you did was
you did a stream where you watched
you watch every single episode of
entourage in a row
50 hours is that 50 hours no breaks 50
hours but we ended it with
the entourage movie ah
i think it ended up being like 53 hours
or something and we stayed up the whole
time yeah how did gil do you remember
how he came up with the idea like what
was gil is again like a genius and and
uh
i i think he's one of the funniest
people ever to live and we did
a project the year before that i
produced
um of his for funny or die where he
stayed up
um
and watched all of two and a half men in
two and a half days
he just kept watching
we put him in a studio
uh so and is he are people watching him
watch it yeah we put him in the studio
yeah on the corner you could see the
the thing
like
the stream of the show and then he
watched it and we made him stay up for
two and a half days launch three and a
half all two and a half minutes from
ashton kutcher like all the way through
oh my god oh my god seasons or something
oh my god
and it was
and it was and we realized like oh the
fun like again
your hook is about
the thing the dumb idea but the fun is
gill it's like seeing gill
up seeing us there seeing us be like wow
we none of us have slept like all that
stuff was
at what point did he did things start to
get really weird i mean in terms of like
just sleep deprivation oh it gets right
away for gil
eight he's like if someone doesn't get
me a falafel
i'm gonna
and so no breaks no bathroom breaks no
he could go to the bathroom he could go
to the bathroom but he could not sleep
he could not sleep oh my god
and so he so he is he laughing at did
the show become like torturous at a
certain point or is it like it yeah
torturous
it was torturous for me
it was with andre oh because you have to
stay up well yeah because we're all you
know me and
and the people producers are staying up
with gail so like the producer like use
fortress to be like what is the bit like
watching a segment
at like six in the morning with oh my
god putting his feet in like uh like
making a bowl of whipping like putting
his feet in it because he's going insane
and you're like what am i how do i did
did
did people watch it i mean was it like
or how many you see how many people are
watching it right on the live stream a
lot of people watch it the worst moment
of that was
someone got in touch the funnier bless
mike farah
yeah yeah
bless the funnier eye people but they
pharah got in touch with the gronkowskis
and on saturday night
after watching
after watching like so many on and
having a board full of like
times when the bechtel test has been
passed it's like a big zero
like just like horrible [ __ ] like times
and times when
jeremy piven has used this slur or
whatever like all over this big board
and
fair was like
rob gronkowski's brother two of his
brothers and agent
want to come
to this
and we were like yeah bring him in
and then they came and i was like
i'm sorry that was a mistake we
shouldn't
and they came in that down and they were
going to beat the [ __ ] out of us why why
just because you were being and realized
that we were making fun of ah
wow can you still see are there did you
ever edit some of that together no i
can't watch it really
because like there are some tough
moments for me i i was shooting
something i had super long hair and
i kept falling asleep
on the couch like it's like
like did somebody wake you up did a
grunky house well like
i would have an ear wiggins so someone
would be like
like pop up and it's like very
embarrassing to wake up to fall asleep
and wake up on camera and like wake up
and be like sorry sorry yeah yeah i
realize you're in the background of a
sketch
i bet like roon
when did they leave and at what point
how did they leave but did they leave in
like a huff yes they left in a hoth
they they left in a huff and it got
tense and and the funnier like people
had to drive over to the house we were
shooting at and me and and john gambling
and the funny type people had to like
have like a uh he's just kidding
why were they so personally
invested in entourage i guess
rob was on it oh
i remember watching that episode with
tom brady and rob and gill
had not slept and he was also being
punchy and also aggressive and funny and
you're all kind of like toeing the line
touching the third rail
and then
and then it kind of exploded and it was
like the moment you had to do that thing
where you're like look he's he's he's he
he's crazy he's a comedian yeah crazy he
doesn't know what he's doing
you know it's like meanwhile they look
back and he's like playing the trumpet
and walking around like it's like
oh [ __ ] i want to see that so badly oh
okay we got a quick lightning round
which now will be a real lightning round
usually it takes a while well what is
your favorite emoji adam kali what's
your go-to emoji that you find yourself
using um the shrug the guy yeah yeah all
right me too i don't know it's useful
who was your first celebrity crush
christina ricci oh in something
particular like in the late night is
that i think like i
you know like similar portman crush
natalie portman was like the first
jewish jewish boy crush that everyone
has like i never cried you know natalie
portman then you're like well i'm
definitely gonna make out without a form
and then
and then
i feel like buffalo 66 uh-huh she's
wednesday adams was like a little older
than me and i always thought she was
like cute and stuff and then remember
she like reserves like buffalo yes yes
that you're done the opposite of sex
yeah well also you have like a
a much more accessible handsome vincent
gallow
uh quality
thank you to your face yeah um so i can
see
your yeah and your general outlook on
life
what is your favorite ice cream flavor
oh um the dolce de leche the haagen-dazs
a little oh what is your favorite
holiday uh hanukkah
yeah okay of course so look i'm not i
don't care yeah
um what is it
what's the fourth of july i love the
fourth of july to celebrate this great
land the day
whatever however we celebrate taking
over
uh dominating indigenous people
i know it's true
that's true
including new year's it's like another
year not really one step closer
what is an acclaimed movie that you're
embarrassed to admit you haven't seen
like people give you [ __ ] for oh
uh this is a good question
i've never seen romancing this stone oh
okay yeah and that's not very critically
acclaimed but i feel like it is our it's
a
pizza big one and that and oh i've never
seen one of the roses i haven't either
though that age group is like i guess
it's like movies that my parents
loved i didn't see for a long time i
hadn't seen the jerk uh and everyone who
i whose sense of humor i i
respected everyone would tell me you got
it and i'm so glad i did i mean i i love
it now but it's um it holds up okay yeah
yeah there's still some really great
stuff it's um well the best thing of the
jerk is like i don't need any of this
i'm just
me
yeah also it's so sweet
talk about a lesson in like efficiency
and like
you know you i know we've both done
movies and stuff where like
romantic stuff where it's like a lot of
talking a lot of dialogue but those two
characters steve martin and bernadette
peters just come together
they play a little they play that
beautiful little like that song you
belong to me you belong to me bernadette
peters
is one of those that's a celebrity crush
me you know yes let's take mine back
okay because minority is a second
celebrity crush okay crush madeline khan
oh yes [ __ ] yeah i mean you and
frankenstein i think marilyn kind was
like my friend and funny
yeah yeah just mostly like funny but she
was the hottest one
yeah
like yeah i think that'll come with my
first boner
she'd be so
she'd be so like i mean
what did it what an honor to hear that
um
by the way i i think that would be nice
to hear if there was a lady boner
somebody was like my first ladybug
if you heard that if something like oh
i'd be so flattered that's a good
comedian but like let's say like
jillian bell
was on a show and they were like who was
your first celebrity crush and she was
like justin long oh
[Music]
yes
especially when you say so romantically
eloquently
what um do you drink coffee or tea and
if so how do you take it i drink coffee
black coffee hot nice that's a cool
answer i mean i would i should start
drinking that just to answer that
question though i'm i'm a cowboy that
way i do i like yeah
coffee black
you like country music
no i'm not a cowboy that way
okay
okay i just got into it i just got into
wayne jennings um i mean like waylon
jennings is different that's like real
that's like real yeah no i i don't like
modern day like florida line or whatever
no no
they're dry like got my beer in one hand
and my chick on another and i'm getting
in the tune your hands are huge dude
yeah
yeah right
he's on a lake and bothering the old
people they're all so rich now too
they're all like the new modern country
music is just sounds kind of
basic and like yuppy i know and like
flaunting wealth and like
got my dogs
limited edition girl going to slow cycle
love the rocks energy drink and nice
much no jews
no jews allowed that's the chorus is
always like
it's but it's a metaphor for acceptance
yeah um really how uh if if you could
learn another language uh what would it
be besides of course the edition hebrew
yes
yes me too i've been trying for a while
have you tried duolingo a little bit i
tried to fall asleep to it but it it
just it's like i'm running the game
especially during this travel show we
were just in puerto rico and like yeah i
don't i'm so worried about being
offensive that it feels like when i get
out of speech managed i'm being
offensive yeah
do you know what i mean like i guess
no no in fact it comes corradato
i know it's like don't do that
what is your um what is your favorite
cereal oh that's tough because i have a
favorite cereal of taste
yeah my favorite cereal of health well
let's do taste because like i started
thinking about my brother and i started
thinking about cereal as like a stoner
treat like i i was looking for healthy
stone or snacks because i was smoking so
much and like eating such garbage like a
paleo um
no no i mean like a [ __ ] like a naughty
cereal for a dessert in place of like
ice cream or whatever
oh okay and what about a healthy cereal
no i'm curious
oh can i like do peanut butter
i go a regular puffing okay and that
should help clean you out man
yeah yeah bowl of puffins you are just
like [ __ ] orange
oh i can't wait that should be on the
box
i think it is
like a real puffin like the birds i've
seen those cliffs
um well if you had to choose a different
first name what would it be besides adam
ooh that's tough
people have asked me that no i'm not
going to be like
i think adam is the only first name that
i could have i wouldn't choose my son's
two names because they're great
yeah
pally is hard you can't do anything hard
you can't do anything with too many
vowels
oh yeah like too many sounds
so
and you can't do anything that ends in a
y
or a p so yeah so like i think adam
haley is kind of perfect yeah it is okay
well there goes we might have to retire
that question i wouldn't change mine i
love my name okay if you had um if you
had a sandwich named after you the adam
pali what would be on it uh i've made
one it is a sesame bagel
oh delicious that's my that's my bagel
choice with tempty whipped cream cheese
on one side
white fish spread on the other
tomato
and onion and capers you had me and you
lost me sorry but i'm not gonna judge it
um i already did what is your favorite
tom hanks movie speaking of joe versus
the volcano a league of their own oh
nice yes good yeah i think it's his best
comedic performance oh yeah she's
[ __ ] great in that yeah that's true
would you rather take a time machine to
the pat not to bring up time machines in
the past or the future oh i've been
asked this too i think now i'd like to
go to the future
because this is going to be a sappy
answer but i'd like to meet my children
as adults
yeah one of the things that when you
lose a pair of young is like i i never i
i'm not under the illusion that i will
know them as adults i might not i'm not
like nothing i think taking a time
machine to the future would be
worth way more than going to the past
yeah that's that isn't it's not sappy
that's a really nice answer um are you
um a night or a morning person i used to
be a night person and now i'm a morning
person the kids right that changes at
all
i also like to be alone i like to be up
before people i like sunrise oh yeah um
toilet do you have a preference to
toilet roll over or under i don't have a
preference my dad got me for my 35th
birthday one of those japanese
day things oh man that's game-changing
game changer so i stopped thinking
really about
yeah yes yeah
yeah
um please finish this sentence adam life
is short so
be nice
well you have been and it's so patient
and [ __ ] great i
i've always liked you so much i'm so
glad we got to do this yeah for sure and
when i get back
more than welcome please let's hang out
i would love it
so
that just happened
he sounds a little like fred savage yes
he does
oh my god just hit me i knew he sounded
like someone yes oh my god
fred savage is a little more uh gruff
yeah he's a little bit more of a
and a little quieter but yeah adam's
just kind of like a little bit more
maybe it's just the chicago yeah maybe
yeah because adam's
adam's got like a different tone he's
got like um his is a little bit make him
sound so annoying no that's not adam
sounds more like this
this is anne
no adam's got um it does not sound like
that but um he's funny he's funny right
that was a good one that was like uh it
reminded me of like a max greenfield
yeah and not not just because they're
jewish but um because
because uh you well you talked a lot
about being jewish so that was in the
forefront of my brain
um but they uh it was a similar dynamic
that you had with them yeah it was it
was like one of those um really good
just a good hang yes just to find like
something that somebody that i could
easily you know have a bunch of beers
with maybe too many better no
responsible amounts yes
um yeah he was that was fun and he is i
see i had no idea he was um
he had gone i didn't know he had gone
through so much and he hadn't dealt with
so much
he's done a lot of work on himself
clearly yeah and he's put and he's how
honest he was about those he's very
thoughtful you know like he's he's uh he
really has a good like
idea of
what he's done in his life and why he's
done it and he's accountability like
he's really thought things through
which is really impressive i thought i
think so too um that entourage live
stream is amazing i can't believe you
did that oh my god i know it reminded me
a little bit about pandemic because you
almost did that you watched so much
entourage i did like
i is like not part of a bit that's right
without a camera on you i watched um
i think the whole series you did yeah i
have memories of like yeah walking by
that room and you were like
stoned in your pajamas
like half asleep
and watching an episode like you weren't
even enjoying it anymore like you just
like have to get through it he said come
on vince we gotta call the man we gotta
call the head of paramount and he's like
i don't know
let me check in with sasha
[Music]
hey turtle you think i should call the
head paramount or do you think we should
go to avalon
you know what i think aphids
kevin connolly would be a good guest on
the show some great episodes of that
wouldn't he we should try
yeah i like his voice he's got a cool
voice at least a little fred savagey too
yes a little scrappy voice i like him a
lot kevin we should try to get him on
yeah we'll just read a letter okay
um okay this is from lisa cassantino
costantino subject love the podcast dear
justin and christian i'm new to your
podcast i found it by listening to
smartlists hey all right thanks to those
guys all right i enjoy listening to it
on my commute to and from work in
guilford connecticut yes all right i
like guilford i'm about half hour away
in hampden oh quinnipiac quinnipiac and
that's where uh my friend uh goodman is
a professor oh right shout out and shout
out to jeff ostrow i grew into school in
hampden you two are so funny and i
really enjoy your brotherly banter i
sometimes laugh out loud at your
conversations before and after the show
i love that you admit that people
probably think
i love that you admit that people
probably think you are gay but by the
way
by the way you talk and interact with
each other you are so honest and real
and just without ego it is such a nice
compliment but um
something else it's like the ultimate
company the ultimate like to be without
ego that's the goal yeah oh man it
doesn't get better than that that's like
the buddha buddha was full of himself he
was no i'm just kidding
back to lisa i've only made a small dent
in your episodes listening to zoey
dashing amy mann patrick wilson simon
pegg michael theo and alicia silverstone
it's made me watch love on the spectrum
all right and revisit clueless and
discover alicia's website and cookbook
so thank you for bringing so much joy
into my life i hope alicia is listening
okay back to lisa this is probably an
obvious one but i've pondered it since i
was little would you rather be blind or
deaf
we have thought about we've talked about
this a lot um
and and yes it's it's a lot not a lot
but i've we've definitely talked about
it uh
lisa says i would choose deaf only
because i have such a fear of walking
around in the dark
well keep up the good work and justin
two of our favorite movies of yours are
accepted in dodgeball you are such a
delight so glad i tuned in we we are too
god what a letter yeah what a great
letter and um that it was that was a
delightful letter delightful sincerely
lisa costantino uh lisa cocentino that
is a good shout out connecticut yeah
guilford um i think i would probably i i
in fact i hate to even choose
you know because it's kind of like
i can choose um hold on wait let me i
know you're saying i know why i don't
want to be um
i think i would
rather be deaf
she'd rather be deaf you know me too
yeah because there's so many i just
things to see and and i i really love
the idea of learning sign language the
sign language to be so expressive and
such a it's such a beautiful way to
express yourself i just saw koda you
know you can learn sign language without
actually being done i know i know i
should i just don't have the work ethic
i just want to know it i just but if you
were deaf yeah you would have you would
have to you would have real impetus
um i would rather be deaf too and just
for like the simplest way to put it is i
enjoy seeing things more than hearing
things yeah you know yeah and i think in
terms just in terms of like
functionality i think it's in the world
yeah but like it would be tough not to
get music or
podcasts like life is short that's true
i i've also met such um i've met such
positive blind people you know because
we used to live near
in new york i lived near the
the school for the blind and
uh for the
sight impaired how would you say is
blind
i don't know i don't know
but um somebody and i
you know i'm such a good person i would
i would offer when i see a blind person
it's hard not to
ask do you need
it's and it's hard to ask that because i
don't want to be condescending or
you know
i i think ever since i saw a scent of a
woman i just want to be like as
respectful as possible i don't want to
be like do you need help you know
to to offer yeah to an adult is a very
because what if you get a thing what if
you get al pacino incentive a woman
don't touch me like that
yeah
i take a flamethrower to this place i
remember being in new orleans with you
and you scampered after a blind person
to help them and they kind of shrugged
it off i think yeah which which because
most
i think what i've discovered in in
because of my ins post my impulse to do
that is that
most the majority of blind people are
totally
fine on their own because they've been
doing it for so long so they know
yeah um and and it's my maybe own
sighted arrogance that that leads me to
think that they do need help it's not
arrogant it's just
it's you not
properly thinking about how the reality
of like if someone's been blind for 40
years or whatever for 30 years
perspective you don't realize how much
uh growth there is yeah and like you
know figuring out how to navigate the
world right now in that time well thanks
lisa thanks lisa and it's a good thing
to think about too i mean i like it
makes me then appreciate
that sure my senses and um what a great
letter i really appreciate that letter
and if you guys would like to write in
like lisa rhoden our email address is
life is short wondery.com thanks
everyone and thanks adam pallett what
what a guy what a guy i can't wait to
hopefully you will be his actual friends
pally because when he said hey we should
hang out we should get together
i feel like you might and he seems like
such an honest guy i don't think he
would have said that worry not no i
think i think he wants to be your friend
and i think the feeling is mutual it is
thank you to everyone and uh we'll talk
to you soon bye
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long yes and megan the monaco
and katie the allen another producer
senior producer is michelle miesh
the audio engineer is sergio henriquez
and the executive producer marshall
louis and it's all done for a company
called wandery
[Music]
and and know it all's not a flattering
thing
so why would you want to think it's not
a thing to think you are
he said she thinks she's a know-it-all
she's
right you should have said she thinks
she knows it all yeah
right she doesn't think she's a
know-it-all
she's a know-it-all well
you can't think you're a know-it-all
even if you are a know-it-all
yeah because you just know it all the
whole point it's a play on something
else so
if you're a know-it-all it means you
think you you think you know it all
right that's the definition of it that's
true
if you say i she thinks she's a
know-it-all
that that doesn't mean anything yeah
it's one of the many things she thinks
she knows
at all
it's a part of all
i never thought about what a know-it-all
that was yeah it's a weird word yeah
but you'd certainly i've never realized
that but you're a know-it-all that's
true you think you're enough
he may have been trying to say he's
defining it she she
doesn't know things but she always
thinks she does
that would be a know-it-all yeah
she bet he should have said she's a
know-it-all
i think that i think
[Music]
if you like our show please give us a
five-star rating and a review and be
sure to tell your friends the next
episode will be out in a week but you
can listen to it right now ad free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app you can follow this show on amazon
music apple podcast and the wondery app
or wherever you're listening right now
in the episode notes you'll find some
links and offers from our sponsors
please support them another way you can
show support for the show is by filling
out a survey at wundery.com survey so
thank you for supporting
you